[MUSIC]
So I recently watched a
TED talk by Jaime Wheal
of the Flow Genome Project.
And the TED talk was
called, "from Altered States
to Altered Traits:
Hacking the Flow State."
Now you guys watch,
"Shots of Awe,"
you know that I'm very
passionate about this idea
of the flow state.
This state of virtuosity
and enhanced performance
among artists and musicians
and writers and elite athletes.
They go into this zone
where they experience
this transient, hypofrontality,
this temporary moment where
the ego dissolves.
You get sort of hyper-focused
in what you're doing.
You drop into Theta states
like meditating monks
and you're able to achieve
excellence and virtuosity that
exceeds normal human levels and
thresholds for what's possible.
We transcend ourselves
in these moments of flow.
And Jamie Wheal, who co-founded
the Flow Genome Project
with Steven Kotler, talks
about it in this TED talk
where he says a lot of us
know these flow states,
but our self systems are
like these colanders.
We're like this
colander full of holes.
And no matter how much
flow we pour into it,
we're always bleeding from
this bucket full of holes.
And so, we achieve these
temporary flow states,
but then Monday, we're
back to where were.
As he says, it's easier
than ever to get high,
it's as hard as it's always
been to stay that way.
But then the idea
of hacking flow
means what if we transform
this colander into a chalice.
What if we could
render ourselves whole.
Or as Jamie says,
render ourselves holy.
What becomes possible with
just one drop beyond that flow?
What becomes possible
with the rest?
I mean it's a wonderful idea.
Most of us, Jamie
says, are still
stuck as like, bliss junkies.
You know, we get
stuck on the state
without raising the stage.
But now, insights into
the neural physiology
of the brain, the
neurochemistry of the brain.
We can actually hack flow.
We can hack nirvana.
We can experience
design and then
do some design, our cities
and our social systems
with positive self reinforcing
feedback loop that teach flow
to make flow an innate,
natural emergence.
This is what becomes possible.
And then, who knows, right?
As Steven Kotler says in the
book, "the Rise of Superman,"
who knows what becomes possible
when we become super-humans.
And it's just a--
it's an awesome idea.
And it's up to us
to make it happen.